a community of meeting our endangered
species they're living in an endangered
forest it's like the tree graveyard this
could be the most important story we
ever cover and you're after
the importance of the Amazon is that it
actually is important to everyone in the
world it isn't just important to those
who live in it all those who work from
what started to worry me or I suppose
surprised me was actually how quickly
the rainforest was disappearing it reads
like alarm bells this vast amounts of
legal and illegal logging and this is
taking place on a pretty frightening
scale by definition the Amazons being
attacked
[Music]
so you got this sort of romantic sense
of this enormous place it's so famous
it's so well-known I was excited but I
was also very aware that it was a
hostile environment it's so easy to say
well it's not a war or it's not a
conflict it is a jungle
it is dangerous you can't just assume
that if something goes wrong or somebody
gets hurt that you can get out so you
have to treat it with a great deal of
respect so that you don't get yourself
into an awful lot of trouble it's also
well documented not just for its dangers
from from nature but danger from mankind
as well we've heard of indigenous people
being wiped out so that people could
take the land off we wanted to go meet
this group with the UH surimi people and
they lived around 130 kilometres down
rivers are quite a ways so we're heading
off the river we're not sure how long a
few hours for certain and so we loaded
up our kit and then you set off and it's
like this is sort of like a proper
adventure because you know you're going
right into the rainforest to go and meet
and business group
initially the Ginga River started out
really wide and that was the first part
of our journey and it was all rather
idyllic and peaceful the incredible
thing about seeing the rainforest
close-up when you're going along the
rivers it is utterly impenetrable it's
literally a wall of trees and foliage it
also got a lot of scary creatures that
could really give you a bad day the
further we got into our journey the more
remote it became and we didn't see any
other boats and then most unexpectedly
we started approaching Rapids so it took
us all a little bit by surprise you know
all of a sudden the boat starts getting
buffeted around and that's when students
started to talk about the well-known
whirlpools in the rivers in the Amazon
region some of these things were huge
and we did hit a few and we were thrown
around and it did get pretty frightening
on a few occasions
you're going pretty fast on this speed
boat and the driver was absolutely
staggering
the boat if it's not big enough and
going fast enough can go down once we
pass through the rapids you start to see
more of the overhanging trees you know
you start to get into a few more of the
narrow waterways wow this is right in
the middle of the Amazon and it's
getting thicker and thicker and thicker
you always get anxiety and a pit in your
stomach just as you're approaching the
location for your shoot this one in
particular none of us really knew what
to expect in terms of the indigenous
crews we're just arriving now into the
village but we've been told that as soon
as we come ashore got to stop filming
until sort of meeting of the people gets
together and they agree that
everything's okay
of course this is the kind of
stereotypical views that you might have
of an indigenous Amazonian group you
know are they going to be closed are
they going to have piercings so we get
there and we were given like a Shack
that was going to be our accommodation
we're running out light now so if
there's a bit of a rush on to get the
hammock set up his chair and then they
said we need to call a meeting because
we have to introduce you to the whole
community
by now is actually dark and so we were
led through the village to the main
gathering hall it was a little bit
intimidating actually because you know
it would totally in their space we
introduced ourselves and I have a little
speech
Dominique gave a little speech Richie
gave a little speech and then they said
yeah you can film and that will you're
welcome I don't know what happens there
normally of an evening but I would
imagine we were fairly you know novel
entertainment for them and so they were
actually in a way reaching out to us to
try and bring their story to people so
that they understand that they are under
threat and then they're scared so after
the meeting that's where the fun for the
evening really began how's your beverage
come see
compact and Bijou oh south-facing aspect
and I'm in here as well right yeah
you're in here when they might love it
so we can snuggle up nice job what
happens if we fall out let's call you
and you get hurt yeah you hurt yourself
cry but let's not do that
we ended up with us being I don't know
about five six feet in the air which is
terrified because you've got to trust
that the two sets of string are actually
gonna hold and then you start to look
around and some pretty nasty spiders
were starting to appear on the wall a
ceasefire which was freaking everybody
out yeah
of course I'd first asked Ricci or
Stuart if they might be willing to get
rid of the spider but they were like no
I'm not going anywhere near that thing
it was huge it was hairy I'll stay back
here and film it yeah I think with all
these things you try to stay in your
hammock and not have to go to the loo in
the middle of the night unfortunately I
failed on that I was next to Stuart and
the lights had just gone out and I
recorded this big Yelp as a bat flew
into Stuart and you know put the wind up
in somewhat but you're in a rainforest
what would you expect
[Music]
when I woke up in the morning the thing
that struck me the most was just how
dead quiet it was it was like total
stillness
Michie and I were out first and he's
filming the river and the first
stirrings of the day beautiful testing
everyone that morning just as I said
looking at things waiting to see what we
were going to do and that apparently was
going to be hunting so we saw the
hunters coming then we had another shout
it's like were you've got to get into
the boats and we head off the dogs are
coming right in probably for another
hour or so up the river as a team we had
agreed that we weren't gonna go deep
into the forest with him because we
weren't equipped to go deep into the
jungle so finally we pull in and they
say this is like the start of the hunt
what we had decided is we would follow
them until they were in hunting and then
once they went up into the forest then
we've seen them often go fishing but we
got to the banks then Ritchie said no
he'd really just like to get a shot of
them going off into the jungle so off
they went and the guys who were the
hunters went with them I last saw
Richard going up a mud banks swearing
and cursing followed by a very reluctant
fisherman who had come with us who sort
of assumed would know exactly where to
go
[Music]
so there any guys who enough on it off
on the hunt without us and we're just
chasing through a jungle now to try and
catch them up
like 20 minutes past and then you know
30 minutes fast and Stuart and I was
sitting on the boat looking at each
other going now if anyone can do the
jungle
it's Ritchie so I gave this up a long
time ago I spent quite a lot of time in
jungles over the years in my previous
military career so I would consider
myself relatively experienced I mean
we've been going around in circles for a
while and done and the I can't tell
which way you're facing I was pretty
confident in his navigation skills but I
have to say I'm starting to doubt them a
little bit
think we lost great it was assumed the
guy was with knew exactly where it was
but it became quite clear to him early
on that he didn't ever clue at all and
that the most qualified was actually
fritzy and I started looking at his face
and he's definitely confusing like the
eyes are giving it all of that and he
was like looking left and right Richie
went offered her Hunter's
he's lost in the young Amazon rainforest
he's weak on for ages these things can
get out of hand pretty quickly it can
become very dangerous but we were a bit
worried because it didn't have anything
with him and of course there's no cell
service it's not like he can just watch
Septim and say hey Richie huh is
everything okay
student and I would say okay if it gets
to another cool in another hour that's
when we'll really start to worry
[Music]
at least seem to have found a hunting
party I mean the probably safe to see
you and suddenly we started hearing a
response and then steered and I looked
at each other thank goodness
cuz I wasn't sure how I was gonna be
able to explain to anybody how we lost
Ritchie in the jungle can hear the boat
shouldn't have doubt in my mate not as
relieved as I am I'm not sure Mikey
Boyer is entirely sure of where we were
and so finally he emerges absolutely
dripping wet with sweat that's me that
is of leaked somewhat back on the boats
and the boys were pointing
and the dog start going crazy in the far
distance you can see a deer his head in
the water swimming try to get tough back
to shore
sort of fairly horrendous to worship
they listen called this dear it was just
about swimming and they saw it suddenly
the boat start rushing forward and
they've got it now the dogs getting back
in no we've got one the village gets a
deer and there was saying this is a good
day they're also saying that the hunting
is getting more and more difficult to
have to go further and further awake
because of deforestation and because of
miners coming onto their land
it's very difficult to get your head
around the fact that that the community
or meeting our endangered species as
well and they're living in an endangered
forest I asked one of them who's the
oldest person in the community and they
took us to him I mean oh he really knows
how old you feel saved over 100 years
but he's on the tribes in the 60s and
70s have been fighting each other
heavily and so one man was sent out to
go and find the outside world and to ask
for help and it was him and he talks
about how he went to see the white man
which is the Brazilians and I think he
said he couldn't believe what he saw a
monkey people appeared seven but yet
really was an incredible privilege to
meet him and when I was shooting
pictures of him I couldn't get a grin
off my face we left the air cerini and
by that stage I feel like we'd even
though we don't speak the same language
we bonded just through body language
they are custodian of this forest which
is vital to our survival and so we're
going to have to find some way to live
in harmony I left there thinking I
wonder if I come back here in a few
years from now whether they'll even
still be here and that was something
that really struck home I think to all
of us that knew with a group is very
special but very very vulnerable at the
same time
[Music]
[Music]
environmental journalism has become as
dangerous as war reporting our producer
said guys this is gonna be one of the
most dangerous assignments that you've
actually done
we knew that people were watching us we
saw people watching us and certainly we
kept as low a profile as possible this
forest is so beautiful and you're
driving along and all of a sudden it's
dawn actually of all the stories we do
around the world this could be the most
important story we ever cover we came
across this area of forest clearings we
had a guy with us Tiago who knows the
forest very well he said it's like a
tree graveyard it felt like any life
that was there was totally gone nothing
everyone was actually quite moved by
this because you don't really think of a
tree being a sort of endangered species
in the same way that you think of an
animal as being one we all just I
suppose couldn't really believe our eyes
because it felt really quite tragic
you're in an area where there is no law
whatsoever if you get into trouble
nobody's coming to help you you're in an
environment which is dangerous hearts
are magic really because it's just in
the middle of nowhere but more people
per capita are killed her than anywhere
else and that's because the amount of
money that can be made from the illegal
logging we had a local security expert
and he said
look guys we gotta get moving actually
we've been here way too long filming
were way too exposed I was thinking well
okay right there is there's a real
threat here these guys aren't going to
mess around so it was dangerous and it
spent a lot of time in the forest and
seeing bits of the forest that had been
chopped up but the only way that we
could really get an idea of the scale
was to do it from the air so we got a
charter flight
this plane is tiny I mean it looks like
about the size of a mini we wings on it
says it kind of six but it's a bit of a
stretch I know me well I had in my head
and what was sitting there were two very
different things
the real solid rotation and then you're
going over the forests that have you
crash in it well no one's ever gonna
find you anyway
so we set off on this trip thinking well
okay well I suppose we just got to do it
and then finally you come over it proper
and it is just enormous amazing as far
as the eye can see
I was looking so forward I like seeds of
a break and it I could see green then I
saw another package agree and then
suddenly the forest disappeared and it
was just a farm that it looked like
rural Oxfordshire that should not be
there that should be the rain forest and
suddenly we're in two mile after mile
after mile thousands of acres after
thousands of acres or farmer
that's exactly where we were going
because we were coming to meet the
ranchers
[Music]
this place was fabulous we're talking
about really wealthy farmers I said it
looked a bit like Southfork from Dallas
you know if jr. Ewing had come out this
would have been like one of those farm
dudes like that Hollywood set fun and
he's a prized cattle yeah they are very
much in denial that actually there's a
lot more logging going on than they
admit you guys don't but I'm just back
down I mean technology but generally
tomorrow's day I get a call tell so piss
off a programmer why shouldn't we
develop more cities forests will make a
comeback the trees will grow back what
was interesting with this farm is it's
modifying its cows as well Wow
goodness then he said oh yeah I want to
show you one of my creations from winter
on this corner and this massive bull was
sitting on the ground I have never seen
anything like it I didn't know something
like that existed on this planet
this thing's like the biggest thing I've
ever seen it's like a hippopotamus
[Music]
absolutely enormous enormous couldn't
stop looking at this thing this beast
and he was so proud of it and actually
at this moment when I came around the
corner rich who was already filming and
I turned the other camera on Richie and
he was like what and I was like wow and
we were although our eyeballs were bit
like whoa it didn't look like regular
cattle I said we're in the middle of the
rainforest with a really high-end
genetically modified cow on a farm
none of which should be here at all and
you just can't help thinking it's just
it's just wrong
this is where you see the real clash of
cultures the indigenous people can't
take these people on if things continue
the way they appear to be going that
there may be nowhere for them to live it
was a short bio incredible period we
spent in the forest and I came away from
that hoping that us out in the civilized
world will do everything possible to
protect it for them all of us demand
things of our societies we want more
range we want more options we want more
food we want more fashion we you know we
drive our economies and our economy
starts in places like the Amazon
rainforest
it appears that we're really on the cusp
of its most the most dangerous period
for many many years that actually that
in the coming months and years then the
damage could be really huge and when you
damage the rainforest like that you'll
never get it back
[Music]
tonight we've reported on two stories
which threaten our planets very
existence here in South Africa we've
witnessed the battle to save the Rhino
from extinction and here in the Amazon
we've seen what happens when big
business and the environment clash we
wanted to bring you raw and unfiltered
images from these two remarkable stories
thanks for joining us and our hotspots
Cruz we look forward to you joining us
on our next assignment as we take you
behind the scenes in some of the world's
toughest places but if you want to talk
about this program please contact me at
ramsey sky on twitter or you can get
hold of Alex at alex crawford sky but
for now from everyone here in south
africa from here in the amazon goodbye
and thanks for watching
you